ええええええ
ずらすジャズらぶたんん
です横にじゃあ肇社長です今日はねこちらは富山県と僕の地元のサッカーチームの
カターレテーマさんの試合の会場に待っております
秘境ぼく何をしようかといいますとカターレ富山産の試合の入場
ピッチに入場する時があるんですけど妄想代向けて僕が紛れ込んでピッチに1級の通り
ますちょっと
か
題材は3のチームのユニフォーム着ていくんで私みんなにばれずに固めた今さんの準備
紛れ込んで入場できるのかどうかを作ってみようと思います
葛してもらっているかフラッシュにあるけれど応用までねー
いきましょう
me
tan
adnan
uh
car
wh
ああああああ
ni
me
none
ああああああ
ええええええ
tee
ウーノそうで逝け
もう一度ねみんな
僕の地元は特価スってますか
静岡じゃないぞいまの静岡に住んでるんですけど僕の地元後富山県でございます僕です
ね今回語る富山産の車で盛り上げるためによっていただきまして今回こんな感じで
ピッチに立たせていただきました本当にありがとうございます後で
サッカーの試合で精神がネットがピッチに立ってすごい大変なんですよ本当に扱い貴重
な経験をさせて頂いて本当にありがとう
ございました一瞬でもあなたにされたことが僕すごい嬉しかったです
でその後で実際ぼく試合勝ってしたんですけどもめちゃくちゃ細い方ですげー惜しい
シーンが多くて
青二代目は鳥肌立ってますねそれを持っていました padi よし焼いてよし当たり
ませんよね試合自体すごい楽しくて本当に満足しました
ん
これでハーフタイムに何か僕がこうステージ立ってマイク出るならしゃべるんですけど
あー見ててくださいよ
こっからどうぞはぁ
ああし
声時代にお礼を1 e 3丁たっけー
て交流が進みたいというつまんでご注意なんですよ
がんばっ名前の小全300食べる麺料理なんですけども
この道庵山にに対する気持ちのをはでる所聞かせていただきますがとうございます
ame
音を誓ったんじゃ本当に惜しかったえっ
そうですね安慶名社長から触れても安全
お高いだけで起動登録おもしろてきましたよ
b 00 ee
ana
ううっうぅううあああの会場に来てくださった皆さん本当にありがとうございました
それが0対0で同時にだったんですけどめちゃくちゃ楽しかったです本当こういう形で
地元のね何かを盛り上げることに参加できてとても僕は嬉しかったです
またね機会があればこういう感じで地元を盛り上げればいいなと思っております
絵とき
くださった皆様そしてカターレちゃえばの皆様本当にありがとうございました
次は試合に出る
me
あっあっ